ladies gentlemen our friends at art
sphere entertainment are added again
Avengers infinity war trailer spoof
toons before we watch this video I want
to give a patron today shout out to a
new patron over here it's called Kurt
Anderson been talking with this guy on
patreon he sent me a message that pretty
much gave me his life story I just
wanted to read it to you guys really
quick I asked him if I could and he said
yeah because I think it's a pretty
awesome story
he said flashback to about 10 years ago
and you find me helping to run one in
Northern California's most notorious
porn companies I'm fat wildly unhealthy
and terribly miserable and a miracle
happens I'm diagnosed with stage 4
cancer with a mortality rate of 80 to 90
percent I changed pretty much everything
I could I threw myself into the fight so
hard that I realized by lying in the
hospital how much I wanted to live to
become the person I wanted to be and
after two surgeries chemotherapeutic
treatments and radiation and went into
remission and I knew that I had to start
being that person I saw myself while
lying in the hospital bed I started
myself down to the barest essentials
just a bag with a few day clothes and a
toothbrush and hit the open road Here I
am a decade later happier than ever at
peace with who I am in the universe I
own nothing I have no address I am the
richest person I know this guy travels a
lot he's been a supporter of our child
for a year I think this is just an
amazing story I was taking a long time
to read this for a game where's the
reaction get to the reaction maybe my
content I know where you guys are
thinking right now but I just want to
say thank you Kirk for sharing that
store because it's a very inspiring tale
you know there's a lot of people who I
feel are working jobs or doing a
lifestyle they just are really unhappy
with and sometimes it takes something so
extreme and I've heard it before where
cancer it can be something that if you
overcome it it just changes your whole
perspective and it's so cool to see that
you have hone in on that and that you're
living the life you want to live so
thank you so much for sharing such an
inspiring story you know I just hope
that for most people including ourselves
that we don't have to wait for something
so drastic to happen for us to make a
life change but sometimes that's what's
necessary so love you buddy and thank
you for sharing much look the five
preview has been approved for imagery
okay
that's a good dog you can do this what
are you doing nothing
are you one of those people who can't
say I thought it started with the T it
does say it again house are you saying
danos like with a net No
are you crazy because I'm saying yeah no
okay so you can't snap your fingers you
can't say no there's a lot of things I
can do
you've just happened to stumble across
my two disabilities well done to you
[Laughter]
hahaha we have to get it anymore don't
worry they assured me it is a painless
procedure
either I finally hit puberty
[Music]
the Chrysler Building looks so majestic
this morning scary when it's completely
out of focus
[Music]
and I super humans and there's six of us
are you blind
he's coming with us this is the expenses
visas parking plus we have with Dennis
one so we can name our price six
thousand eight thousand and then there's
postage and handling sales tax finder's
fee we're looking at a cool twenty to
fifty aren't you like a billionaire sure
how do you think I became one
so in weapons to terrorists no common
mistake it was swindling intergalactic
super boons okay your plan sucks let me
do the plan because I once came up with
twelve percent of a plan and I saved the
whole planet either thirty percent of
the plan should be enough to save the
universe
um that's some questionable math Peter
shut up Peter
oh hey I am Spyder mr. stark what are
you wearing well you stole the last of
my iron so I guess I'm like rowspan Dex
man now see this that's on you I'm
seeing all these guys I can't it's my
character now talk to me you're just a
publicity stunt
[Music]
[Music]
oh I am professor unusual unusual and
dangerous and attractive PhD the anus
movie now we do we need a whole two
three language of the anus childhood
movies is watching that looks like my
favorite version of Teen Titans go but
with the young Thanos yeah that's a
prequel origin story I would like to see
it just so we could understand why he is
the way he is because he was bullied and
called the anus and school that's tough
man is a tough way to come up thank you
from a guy whose last name starts with
hump you know yeah we'll take it from a
guy who's related to and married to
Jessica Biel what a [ __ ]
I like their approach to spoofing things
you know I know some people can compare
these guys to the like love a channel
like how it should have ended in a way
how it should have ended well they will
do their like pop-culture references the
ad
pop-culture references within a pop
culture already video these guys will
more usually take like a line or
something or something very specific and
kind of have sort of a of a spoof moment
of it twist on it rather than throwing
in like another crazy reference with her
like not snapping her fingers well how
do you say fan oohs how are you saying
it mania what else might have happened
yeah alternate version of this scene and
I feel like especially seeing this one
their grip on a parody version of
Marvel's banter is actually pretty good
cuz I'm like I can see this being an
outtake er or a D'Elia you know improv
scene or something in some of these
moments because when he says like tell
me his name again they could have just
done some crazy pop culture reference or
throw in some other Marvel or DC
character or whatever but instead it
just becomes a bit about how he said
tell me his name again
yeah understanding what he's like Angie
Zhuang banter based joke or making fun
of luck when he takes off the glasses
and looks at it wow it's even still
scary like that or vision opening the
window and he's naked cuz like oh yeah I
mean if they're sleeping together
together at that time you know but then
they will do like their additional
pop-culture references MJ appearing on
the school bus that's a good joke and
riff on the idea of how literally no one
saw it and the way the movie cuts that
scene together it makes sense
no one saw but there is also that side
of you're like one person using
character of the MJ character yeah so
like the way they had to do their Tony
Stark character because everyone else
seems like the characters like they got
like the voice of Tom haulin sounds
great but the Robert Downey jr.
character is just like I don't know why
but that just perfectly translates for
me yeah and they say it in every video
that it's just these two who are putting
these videos together and feel like
these guys are like a married couple who
live in some state far away from
California yeah
and I'm making these you know there's
yeah it's very impressive what they do
and they put a hell of a lot of work
into their videos and I remember when we
and I first saw these guys you know they
were less than a hundred thousand
subscribers and that was around the time
of superhero Bowl now there are five
hundred sixty thousand followers and
they kill so these guys are killing it
right now and please keep up the work
you guys are on your ways to be one of
the biggest channels right now it's
always a treat when one of y'all's
videos drive absolutely so thank you so
much we will definitely sit we are we
are subscribed how do you learn about
this video being afflicted the
notification bell which you can also too
for us yeah yeah please do subscribe
subscribe to them subscribe to us click
bells all those things I love you every
one of my people that I know I love
everyone